[Musik]
ein bisschen wissen kann nicht schaden
selten traf diese harmlose satz so zu
wie in diesen wochen da in europa krieg
geführt wird tausende menschen sterben
verletzt und heimatlos werden ganze
städte in schutt und asche liegen und
millionen menschen geflüchtet sind ein
bisschen historisches wissen auch und
gerade zu den ereignissen die uns gerade
beschäftigen woher sollte es kommen wir
nicht aus den köpfen derer die bücher
schreiben bücher lesen bücher
produzieren und es sich zur aufgabe
gemacht haben über
geschriebenes nachzudenken
dieser podcast richtet sich an
reflektierende wesen ich führe dazu ein
gespräch mit katharina raabe der für ost
europäischen literaturen zuständigen
lektoren des suhrkamp verlags sprechen
mit ihr über zahlreiche ukrainische
autorinnen und autoren und will dabei
immer bedenken dass sie liebes publikum
die relevanten sprachen dazu genauso
wenig sprechen wie ich deswegen schreibe
ich ihnen eine liste mit autoren und
werken in die show notes auf unserer faz
website und am ende des podcasts nenne
ich noch einmal die wichtigsten
buchtitel damit sie wenn sie nur mit dem
smartphone unterwegs sind auch allein
mit diesen hinweisen weiterkommen heute
ist sonntag der dritte april 2022 ich
bin paul ingendaay
und ich freue mich dass sie dabei sind
ich sitze hier mit katharina raabe
langjährige lektorin im suhrkamp verlag
und wirklich die verantwortliche für die
große nähe des deutschen literatur
publikums zu russischer ukrainischer
belarussische und anderer literatur ich
verdanke ihr viele viele namen und texte
aus osteuropäischen literaturen und wir
haben uns vor acht tagen bei der
veranstaltung auf dem bebelplatz in
berlin gesehen bei der kundgebung die
unendlich bewegend war im alle gefroren
aber es war fantastisch und sie haben
sie mit organisiert diese veranstaltung
wie auch eine veranstaltung im gorki
theater in berlin
können sie beschreiben wie das ist jetzt
aktiv werden zu müssen auf eine weise
die sie sich nicht gedacht hatten
es war zunächst der schock des überfalls
putins auf die ukraine und natürlich
waren meine gedanken zuallererst bei
meinen freunden und freundinnen den
autoren und autorinnen dort und
natürlich auch bei der frage was tun wir
jetzt als als menschen des wortes und es
kam dann ganz spontan die idee übrigens
durch olga des kaya die noch einmal an
ihre übersetzung von marias der pano was
gedichtzyklus der krieg der tiere und
der und ihre blätterte und sagte mein
gott sie hat jahr 2015 schon alles
vorhergesehen
jetzt lasst uns doch einfach mal gucken
was finden wir in den texten ja und dann
habe ich mich hingesetzt und meine
ukrainischen autoren befragt die bücher
schnell in die hand genommen und dann
innerhalb von anderthalb stunden
deutschsprachige autorinnen und autoren
gefragt ob sie zwei tage später im gorki
theater aus den büchern ihrer
kolleginnen lesen würden und dank
johannes kirsten dem chefdramaturgen am
gorki-theater der sofort dafür war haben
wir das dann auch in einer großen
kraftanstrengung gestimmt also zwei tage
nach ausbruch des krieges und ich muss
sagen das war unendlich bewegend diese
texte in diesem neuen licht zu hören die
texte von juri andruchowytsch von
jewgeni below rositz von katharina
mission koo von seriöser dann aber eben
auch von russischen kollegin maria
stepanowa und der mutigen alisa gar nie
war und so weiter was halten sie von der
idee
diese durch die veltins geisterte
die russischen künstler künstlerinnen
die nicht sich distanzieren
auszuschließen von der aktivität im
kulturleben naja was heißt sich nicht
distanzieren
kennen sie fällt man sich ein bisschen
als zweifelsfall sehen könnte nein ich
habe nie mit künstlicher künstler und
autoren gemieden die den neo imperialen
geist den man in der russischen
literatur seit etwa 2002 34
wahrnehmen konnte ich habe diese autoren
gemieden ich habe sie zur kenntnis
genommen ich war erschrocken als ich im
jahr 2009 sah wie eine figur wie sacher
prix debüt mit hunderttausende auflagen
riesigen konterfeis in den moskauer
buchhandlungen prangte und dass dieser
sache abrieb in der von seinem
ukrainischen kollegen sehrezad durchaus
geschätzt wurde plötzlich
2014 auf der anderen seite stand seit
april etienne war ein propagandist des
sogenannten no borussia projektes und
sachprämien ist einer der im donbass
gekämpft hat mit einem regiment er wurde
ein physischer feind seines kollegen
sehr schade und das seltsame war dass
man das 2009 in dieser neo sowjetischen
helden literatur schon wahrnehmen konnte
es ist interessant das heißt dass man es
eigentlich recht eindeutig sehen kann
früh sehen konnte und dann auch seine
schlussfolgerungen ziehen konnte und
dass diese kennzahl geschichten die wir
in den letzten wochen erlebt haben zum
teil auch aus dem übersehen von indizien
bestanden haben müssen aus frühen
zeichen die man nicht gelesen hat naja
ich glaube man hat die zeichen gelesen
und wir haben ja jetzt keine
reichhaltige russische
gegenwartsliteratur die von der man sich
distanzieren müsste das möchte ich mal
klar sagen es ist wir haben keinen
waleri gergiew im literatur leben und
waleri gergiew hätte man zum beispiel
niemals meiner meinung nach in münchen
verpflichten können jeder aufmerksame
zuschauer hätte schon im jahr 2008 hören
können wie gergiew ins team war die in
südossetien vor die kameras trat und von
einem genozid der georgier an den
russischen bewohner südossetien sprach
das heißt gergiev ist ein mann mit engen
verbindungen zu putin erteilt seine
imperiale weltsicht und das hätte man
wissen müssen aber ich beobachte ja dass
in deutschland auch im internationalen
kultur leben vor allem in den
performativen künsten die sehr viel geld
im spiel haben dass da eine gewisse
naivität vorherrscht und gazprom fördert
natürlich großartige festivals und jeder
der mal in russland war und diese neuen
musik festivals besucht hat sei es in
perm oder auch die weißen nächte in
petersburg usw man schwimmt in kultur
man hat geld dafür aber dieses geld ist
schmutzig und die autoren und künstler
mit denen wir bei suhrkamp
zusammengearbeitet haben das waren
diejenigen die sich davon ferngehalten
haben und einige von denen sind jetzt in
gefahr und einige von denen haben auch
schon das land verlassen haben denn die
künstler die autorinnen und autoren mit
denen sie arbeiten und gearbeitet haben
wie sie darauf aufmerksam gemacht oder
sogar gefordert
distanzen einzuhalten beziehungsweise
haben sie ihre kollegen die er eben
staatstreue putin nahe waren
er ist nicht sagen die familie aber
charakterisiert als
unmöglich als nichts nichts reputeer
lich im politischen sinn ein dass das
war ja gar nicht nötig das haben wir wir
nein das ist nicht nötig weil wir das ja
alles alle selbst gesehen haben also es
sie gehen ja jetzt nicht nach moskau in
ein verlag und lassen sich die neuen
titel vorlegen sondern unser
literarisches leben und auch dass das
suchen nach neuen stimmen
der kontakt mit den vielen übersetzern
mit den veranstaltern auch mit
denjenigen die sich als journalisten
auch als historiker als politologen mit
russland beschäftigen als mit diesem
land das wir ja eigentlich lieben und
dessen kultur mir jedenfalls immer sehr
sehr nahe war und auch bis heute noch
nah ist wir haben das ja gesehen was
dort geschieht wir haben ja gesehen wie
ein mann der aus dem geheimdienst kommt
sich diese diese literatur quasi als als
ressource unterwirft also die
russland importiert ja nicht nur öl und
gas sondern russland importiert auch so
eine große
musik und seine sein ballett und seine
literatur und die letzten jahre auf der
frankfurter buchmesse es war
alptraumhaft diesen russischen staates
stand zu sehen und auch zu zu zu spüren
wie
große schriftsteller puschkin der
monteur fall die die diese fürchterliche
russische seele beschworen haben wie uns
die verkauft wurden wirklich als
kulturelle ressource als ein als ein
integraler bestandteil des großen
nationalen russischen projekts und
niemand sich spreche ich jetzt immer von
uns es ist sehr unlauter ich möchte nur
von mir sprechen und von meinen freunden
freundinnen in den verlagen wir haben
uns immer sehr der
zivilgesellschaft den
zivilgesellschaftlichen akteuren
zugehörig gefühlt wir hatten sehr viel
mit memorial zu tun wir hatten mit
mitmenschen wie paris dubai oder left
off die us soziologen die neo
totalitären strukturen die sich bildeten
seit dem machtantritt putins die das
beschrieben haben mit denen hatten wir
zu tun ich habe bücher über den
tschetschenienkrieg gemacht ich habe
einen autor michael klien der ein buch
nach dem anderen geschrieben hat über
die sogenannte gelenkte demokratie
und ich muss auch sagen
in den nuller jahren habe ich die
spannende literatur aus diesem tal
osteuropas nicht in russland sondern in
der ukraine gefunden dazu komme ich
jetzt meine frage ist nämlich wie
könnten sie durch jahrelange
textkenntnis gewappnet dafür eine
unterscheidung treffen in temperament im
charakter in der art des erzählens
zwischen russischer und ukrainischer
literatur bedenken dass zwischen den
beiden natürlich größten ehen und
überlappungen stattfinden ja durch
kultur die sprache
na ja wir waren erst mal gar nicht gut
vorbereitet
ukrainisch ist eine ganz andere sprache
als russisch also wer russisch gut kann
und polnisch gut kann wird das
ukrainische schnell lernen aber jemand
die mühe und not russisch gelernt hat
wie ich die musste mit ukrainisch ganz
neu anfangen und als ich damit begannen
mich überhaupt mit ukrainischer
literatur zu beschäftigen gab es gar
keine wörterbücher gab es auch gar keine
grammatiken das heißt diese sprache
existierte in unserer deutschen welt gar
nicht anders als in polen und die ersten
informationen über die sehr aufregende
verspielte karnevaleske
geradezu bilderstürmerei ukrainische
literatur erreichte mich über polen denn
die polnisch ukrainischen beziehungen
sind traditionell sehr eng und es gab
ganze übersetzer dynastien aus lemberger
zeiten noch die dafür gesorgt haben dass
eine autorin wie oksana sabuschko oder
ein auto wie juri andruchowytsch nicht
zehn 15 jahre lang übersehen wurden und
so bin ich eigentlich durch die
persönliche bekanntschaft mit juri
andruchowytsch der wiederum mit einem
unserer polnischen autorin angie
starship eng befreundet war und
gemeinsam reisen unternommen hat und
sogar ein gemeinsames buch gemacht hat
über europa ich bin durch durch diesen
polnischen weg zu juri andruchowytsch
gekommen und das erste buch das wir dann
machten war auch er ein buch das aus
fragen meinerseits
bestand also ehrlichen sinne frage hatte
er hatte es geschrieben bzw eine
polnische verlags kollegin monika
schneider mann hatte ein bändchen
gemacht das letzte territorium und das
waren sehr heterogene texte die zum teil
von galicien handelten oder von
tschernobyl oder von so einer
phantasmagorien idee dass das
karpatenbecken ein ausgestorbenes mehr
war und es hatte auch ein es ist ja auch
ein text gern maske über den das
weggehen aus der ukraine das juckt mich
immer das an das buch erinnern dass hat
einen unendlichen charme und hat
eigentlich was ich weiß nicht ob die
verkaufszahlen das spiegeln aber der
zauber den es ausübt auf jemanden der in
osteuropa interessiert ist hier ist
unbekanntes territorium hier gibt es
unendlich viel zu entdecken und hier
sieht die welt wie bei star shakira oft
zu lesen auch den polen der ja auch auf
dem dorf wohnen der und ja draußen in
der provinz hier ist die welt ganz
anders als ihr euch vorstellen könnt es
war ein ein türöffner dieses buch
welches jahren also dass gerade 2003
2002 oder 2003 und es war auch ein
wunder der rezeption alle haben dieses
büchlein gleichzeitig gelesen ist für
sich entdeckt und sie werden sich glaube
aber es ist in der siebten auflage
und damit war mein buch das im
buchhandel denkbar
unbeliebt ist nichts schlimmer als eine
sammlung von essays dieses buch war ein
reiseführer es war eine kulturelle
exploration ist sehr viele
anknüpfungspunkte jüdische geschichte
tschernobyl alles mögliche
sie hatten ein element schon genannt bei
der ukrainischen literatur dieses gerade
was jetzt bei juri andruchowytsch
typisch ist ja das hat etwas mit
fabulieren zu tun überbordende fantasie
verschiedene genres die er mischt große
gelehrsamkeit die aber spielerisch
daherkommt und wir hatten vor wenigen
wochen in der zeitung in der faz ein
langes interview mit ihm indem er ihre
sachen gesagt hat darunter auch dass er
eben wenn es drauf ankommt auch als
partisan kämpfen würde also da ist da
verbindet sich große kreativität mit
großer tapferkeit und das haben wir doch
bei einigen dieser autoren jetzt in
letzten wochen gehört meine frage ist
könnten sie noch ein paar andere
stichpunkte nennen sehr knapp um diese
literatur abzusetzen etwa von der
russischen diese literatur hat sehr
viele verschiedene traditionen also man
muss sich klarmachen dass die ukraine
wie karl schlögel ist oft gesagt hat in
europa im kleinen ist es ist eine
literatur die auf den trümmern der
großen imperien auf ruth das heißt es
gibt eine österreichische tradition eine
polnische joseph roth bruno schulz sind
autoren auf die sich juri andruchowytsch
bezieht es gibt den großen sowjetischen
komplex im osten des landes
es gibt die sowjetischen die
ukrainischen futuristen auf die einen
autorisierten der einigen fast eine
generation jünger ist als juri
andruchowytsch sich bezieht und die
haben ein vollkommen anderen rahmen in
dem sie sich bewegen also sowie juri
andruchowytsch die alte österreichische
palimpsest heftigkeit einer stadt wie
lemberg oder stanislaus die war frank
ybbs ausgräbt und die karpaten mythen
sucht und die hochschulen musik gestört
so ist dieser dann in der post seien in
dem sowjetischen raum mit seinen auch
mit seinen kriegerischen
hinterlassenschaften also den den
wehrmachts helmen im boden aber eben
auch den großen bauprojekten in hartz iv
und eben dieser dieser
welt eine avant garde die in den 30er
jahren von stalin abgewürgt wurde und
sachschaden ist ein ist ein lyriker
übrigens wie julia grosch auch aber er
hat sich immer in einen politischen
kontext des anarchismus des links sein
und des agitatorischen gestellt ich habe
noch mal ein buch hervor genommen warum
ich nicht im netz binden gedichte und
prosa von ca
und wenn man das heute sich nochmal
anschaut das ist erschienen 2016 sie
haben es hier als großes format der
edition suhrkamp das ist sehr schön
geworden dadurch und erweckt auch eine
andere aufmerksamkeit als die üblichen
bändchen und dieses dieses buch
versammelt sowohl ein bisschen prosa
tagebuch aber eben vor allen dingen auch
lyrik und es ist großenteils lyrik aus
dem krieg und über den krieg und aus dem
was er 2014 gesehen erfährt sehr viel
rum er hat eine band und auch dieses
musiker sein lyriker sein erzähler sein
ein reflektierter auto einerseits aber
auch möglich mit beiden füßen in der
aktions steht nämlich künstlerische
aktion mit anderen kumpels fahren sie
los und begegnen auch durchaus nicht
ganz ungefährlichen situation ist
beschreibt das klingt jetzt so ein
bisschen harmlos wie sie das sagen also
erfährt nicht mit kumpels los sondern er
hat seine band dieser backkurs die
meinte ich damit die hunde im weltall ja
aber die machen nicht nicht klamauk
sondern die fuhren damals an die orte wo
die sogenannten separatisten
mit dem terror begannen die die foren an
die orte die plötzlich nicht mehr
zugänglich waren weil gesetzlosigkeit
herrschte und sie sind zu den
freiwilligen helfern und auch kämpfern
gefahren um für die musik zu machen das
heißt sie waren
im kriegsgebiet in dem gebiet in dem
dieser die reguläre krieg der nie krieg
genannt werden durfte damals aufflammte
und es ist die heimatregion von sascha
tansanische dann ist als
junger russisch sprach ich aufgewachsen
ist der obelisk im raum lohans karubis
ist berühmt weil es dort ein
kriegsgefangenenlager gab in dem vor
allem polnische auch polnische
schriftsteller gesessen haben in den
40er jahren und seriöser dann hat als
junger mensch beschlossen seine
literatur sprache wird das ukrainische
und in seinen büchern reden die leute
russisch aber wir lesen das ukrainisch
und dann natürlich noch ins deutsche
übersetzt von unseren tollen
übersetzerinnen aber das ist ein
phänomen das man sich ja mal klar machen
muss also diese sprache die dort
gesprochen wird und die er kopiert hebt
er zugleich ins ukrainische weil er das
gefühl hat diese sprache ist sachlicher
diese sprache ist schön es ist auch die
sprache der emanzipation der ukraine aus
dem sowjetischen kontext und
gleichzeitig ist er anders als andere
hobbys jemand der diese sowjetischen
hinterlassenschaften durchaus ernst
nimmt also die große oktobersonne über
den feldern also seine lyrik ist voll im
grunde von einer mit erfolg und einer
bildlichkeit die wir von diesen großen
als realistischen künstlern der großen
utopie kennen und etwas von dieser
großen utopie schleppt er mit sich herum
in vieler hinsicht aber ironisch also es
eben kein imperiums propagandist wie
sein kollege sascha prämien auf der
anderen seite der grenze sondern er ist
jemand der das träumerische an diesem
großen projekt der befreiung ernst nimmt
und was sehr wichtig ist was man nicht
oft genug betonen kann serie ja dann ist
sozusagen ein politischer aktivist des
sprechens in seinen büchern und es hat
mich sehr bewegt in den büchern die salz
2012 ungefähr entstanden sind ist immer
immer deutlicher dieses motiv zu
vernehmen leute spricht miteinander
wir sind alle menschen dieses ist unsere
unser unser land unsere region und wie
kommt ihr da auf euch auf einmal die
köpfe einzuschlagen
setzt euch hin redet guckt wie es euch
geht und lasst euch nicht von den
ideologen und von den scharfmachern
gegeneinander aufhetzen diesen eindruck
vermittelt das buch auf vielen ebenen
was sie gerade gesagt haben nicht nur in
den prosastücken wo er tatsächlich von
vom zusammenkommen vom sprechen und zu
dem versuch zu sprechen auf jeden fall
und wir auch in recht lockerem ton der
sicherlich auch den ernst der lage ein
bisschen über spielt manchmal
ein bisschen charakterisiert wer wohl
was denken mag oder welche ressentiments
schlummern mögen in den einzelnen köpfen
es gibt hier einige absolut bewegende
gedichte die auch mit dem pathos einer
älteren wirklichkeit spielen was das
hier gerade erwähnten die wirklich
ergreifend sind weil natürlich unsere
generation der leser und dazu zähle ich
jetzt mal alle unter 70 die jagd selber
kein krieg erlebt haben wenn sie wenn
sie deutsche sind da schreibt er zum
beispiel serie ja dann in einem gedicht
das anfängt mit der zeile eine stadt an
der front am tag vor der weihnachts hat
kein titel das gedicht da gibt es eine
kleine strafe die ich ganz kurz mal
lesen möchte wer von euch männern bleibt
heil diesen winter wer wird vom anderen
ufer weg finden wer stürzt in den schnee
wen zieht und das eis die fische zu
füttern mit seinem fleisch die erde mit
salzigen blut zu trinken echo zu sein im
vogel gekreischt hier hat die
übersetzung durch claudia daad und
esther kinsky auch noch die die laut
lichkeit versucht oder den fans und den
reim sogar versucht reinzuholen ich
finde das sehr gelungen und sehr
beeindruckend weil es ein tonis den wir
in der zeitgenössischen lyrik anderswo
kaum kennen hier ist etwas ganz eigenes
das andere an diesem buch was ich auch
faszinierend findet das betrifft jetzt
auch den verlag und auch sie in ihrer
arbeit sie haben hier ein band
komponiert ist die deutsche ausgabe so
komponiert auswahl aus mehreren
gedichtbänden dann zum teil aus
unveröffentlichten gedichten das war
also 2016 und eine art tagebuch rosa in
der er schildert wie er durch die gegend
fährt und die gespräche führt von der
von denen sie gerade erzählt haben wenn
sie so einen plan fassen die lange
dauert es von dem plan bis zur umsetzung
ist der autor sofort bereit zu sagen ich
mache mit der auto ist sofort bereit zu
sagen ich mache mit und wir sind
eigentlich immer immer im gespräch
schreibt ziemlich viel und
ich beobachte waren die phasen einsetzt
wenn er zum beispiel die prosa verlässt
und und und wieder lyrik schreibt und es
war so nach dem lustigen roman internat
der ja in einem ungenannten ort im don
was spielt mitten im krieg dieser ort
ist vermutlich de balme gewesen wo die
entscheidende schlacht stattfand und
nach diesem roman musste er glaube ich
eine pause machen und ist zurückgekehrt
zur lyrik aus der er ja auch kommt und
als wir letzten winter also vor wenigen
wochen als serie wieder anfing
interviews zu geben und hier und da ein
sc zu schreiben und die stimme
eigentlich immer
ernster und verzweifelt passt auf wenig
ernster wurde habe ich ihn gefragt ob er
sich vorstellen kann für uns jetzt eine
art von sammlung dieser essays zu machen
oder ob er so etwas wie die chronik der
laufenden ereignisse schreibt in dem
buch das sie gerade erwähnt haben ist ja
die prosa hinten das ist sein buch hans
k tagebuch und das duo hans kall
tagebuch hat er zum teil auf facebook
veröffentlicht und zum teil für den
druck noch mal neu bearbeitet aber es
ist bei uns sozusagen usus dass wir
immer versuchen solche mischformen zu
finden und der der letzte band jüngste
band antenne der vor zwei jahren zwar
2020 erschienen da hat er zum beispiel
ein in der originalausgabe nicht
vorhandenen prosatext über den tod
seines vaters geschrieben der sehr
berührend ist und der einem auch den
eindruck gibt eine epoche geht zu ende
und
marcel hirscher dann sind diese zeichen
sehr
klar auch wenn ich niemals so weit gehen
würde wie die leute die dieses können
solche kassandra projekte lieben ich
würde niemals so weit gehen zu sagen ja
die haben das alles vorausgeahnt nein
sie haben einfach genau beschrieben
dass wir jetzt auch meine nächste frage
gewesen wir haben den letzten wochen
eine einzigartige beschäftigung nämlich
aus guten gründen mit der ukrainischen
literatur mit den stimmen dieser
literatur betrieben in deutschland
natürlich aus nachholbedarf wir wollen
wissen und das sind mit die besten
zeugen dies gibt weil sie sich
artikulieren können manche von ihnen
wohnen in deutschland vielleicht können
wir mal ganz kurz so 22 gruppen kurz
festhalten annahmen mir ist jetzt hier
aufgefallen natürlich das also seriöser
dann den sie gerade genannt haben juri
andruchowytsch und oksana sabuschko
die sind noch da bzw sind in gefahr und
müssen woanders hingehen in ihrem land
sind aber noch nicht ausgewandert sind
noch nicht geflohen dann gibt es aber
auch
autorinnen wie katja petrowsky die in
deutschland wohnt und sich hier auch
sehr markant äußert sascha marianna
salzmann
ebenfalls die haben jeweils andere
geschichten aber die können natürlich
sehr beitragen zu einer sage ich mal für
vertiefungen dieses dialogs den es gibt
gerade heute der findet gerade in den
für toms doch sehr wahrnehmbar statt
welches ist ihr eindruck ist dass ist
das gut genug was da da da läuft sehr
viel in meinen augen aber was kann man
noch mehr tun ich finde es sehr wichtig
und auch sehr schön dass diese
ukrainischen autorinnen als ich möchte
unbedingt auch tanja maria schuck nennen
die ja schon seit 2010 in wien lebt und
mittlerweile auch auf deutsch schreibt
dass diese autorinnen auch eine
wiegender teil 1 an der kasseler danko
die jetzt den in budapest eigentlich
gestrandet ist dass diese autorinnen zu
wort kommen oder yorker brokers gut ja
noch in in lemberg
sitzt und das psychoanalytiker arbeitet
und flüchtlingsfamilien beherbergt das
gemeinsame an diesen autorinnen und
autoren und das macht es für das
deutsche feuilleton ja auch so einfach
die sprechen deutsch
es ist ja ein phänomen das wir zum
beispiel auf dem bebelplatz neulich also
ich denke auch an jewgenia beloruss
jetzt die in kiew sitzt berichtet
tagebuch schreibt und fotografiert dass
diese leute alle deutsch sprechen und
das macht natürlich auch die große die
große faszination und im grunde auch die
chance aus dass sie uns erklären können
was dort geschieht und katja petrowsky
die sich ja nicht als ukrainischer
autoren bezeichnen würde sie es ja so an
ein ein wesen im grunde aus einem
russischsprachige jüdischen familie in
kiew stammend ende der 90er jahren nach
deutschland gekommen
debütiert hat sie auf deutsch
als ihr buch erschien im frühjahr 2014
war der europa dann gerade auf der kippe
und dann setzte sich diese revolution
durch und ist geschehen dinge die uns
irgendwie
verstört haben und katja petrowsky aber
die einzige die in der lage war diese
vielen verschiedenen perspektiven
einzunehmen die erklären konnte warum es
dort eigentlich auf dem majdan gegangen
ist ich würde gerne weil sie den namen
genannt haben ein zitat an bringen hier
weil es ist natürlich eins was ein
aufrüttelt und ein nachdenklich macht
und einen auch im grunde wie vor eine
wand stellt nämlich da geht der weg
nicht so einfach weiter das hat sie vor
kurzem hier in der fas in einem großen
interview gesagt wo 32 autorinnen und
ein autor sprachen sie sagte katja
petrowsky ja wir waren zwar allemal
pazifisten aber jetzt sind wir es eben
nicht mehr vor den entscheidungen stehen
die gerade
ja vor uns liegen also vor den
überlegungen auch die karl schlögel hier
auch geäußert hat
das ist jetzt eine frage die geht sehr
weit und sie müssen das nicht
beantworten aber es würde mich schon
interessieren wie denken sie über den
krieg nach wenn karl schlögel etwas sie
brauchen ein schutz des luftraums über
der ukraine damit dieses land überhaupt
überleben kann unter dem gegenwärtigen
ansturm und dann kommen die strategen
zum teil auch die
flämische strategen und sagen großer
gott dann ziehen wir die nato in diesen
krieg rein welche gedanken machen wir
als büchermenschen uns über den krieg
und über die strategie wie
lehnsessel strategen kenne ich nicht ich
habe wahrgenommen dass auch ein mensch
wie karl schlögel der der
leidenschaftlicher und
empathischer als viele seiner historiker
kollegen verfolgt hat was in der ukraine
geschah diese gesellschaft verfolgt hat
die sich in dem majdan aufstand gebildet
hat und die jetzt
existenziell physisch bedroht ist und
vernichtet werden soll wenn er so etwas
sagt dann sagt er dass im grunde als
solidaritäts zeichen mit denjenigen in
der ukraine jurij andruchowytsch ich
kenne keinen dieser autorinnen und
autoren die nicht sagen schließt den
himmel über der ukraine was für ein
poetischer ausdruck aber was das heißt
das wissen ja nicht einmal die
militärstrategen deswegen ist es für
mich persönlich eine ein großer
zwiespalt
ich verstehe dass ich möchte das auch
sagen ich sage es auch ich finde es ein
skandal dass wir hier sitzen und zu
gucken wie putins truppen und bomber
eine friedliche sich selbst
organisierende gesellschaft vernichten
wollen das ist ein skandal und wir
wollen natürlich alles tun damit das
verhindert wird aber wenn die menschen
die sich in den stäben auskennen sagen
es wird dann das und das und das
passieren dann ist es die reine
spekulation ich glaube wir müssen weiter
darüber nachdenken
wie wir es überhaupt aushalten dass das
geschieht das hier krieg herrscht und
dass wir auch begreifen diese
gesellschaft muss bewaffnet werden diese
gesellschaft kann sich nur schützen wenn
sie waffen hat und wenn sie kämpft und
sie es bereits zu kämpfen dass wir
überhaupt so weit kommen würden dass
eine friedliche
selbstverwaltet ich habe das gesehen auf
dem majdan als es vorbei war mich haben
leute dort herum geführt und ich habe
einen text verlegen können von katharina
mission koo der meydan als agora also
wir haben gesehen dass dort eine
bürgergesellschaft entstand mit
horizontalen strukturen und diese
gesellschaft die sich gefunden hat und
die ihren eigenen staat aufbauen wollte
wird von putin der als solche
bestrebungen in seinem eigenen land
brutal unterdrückt hat den soll das
rückgrat gebrochen werden und wir wollen
ihnen das rückrat stärken ja und es gibt
dazu eben aus diesem selben interview
sieht erwähnten vorhin tania maria job
sie war auch beteiligt an diesem großen
interview und hat dort auch wirklich
denkwürdige sachen gesagt ich möchte
einen satz daraus lesen zwei sind es ich
schaue in den abgrund meiner ganzen welt
die mit allen meinen freunden vor der
physischen vernichtung steht es ist
unmöglich sich damit abzufinden
das ist der eine satz und der andere ist
von coco rocha sco
der sagte es sei wichtig das war wichtig
ich zitiere die zivilgesellschaft zu
üben durch unsere zwei maidens und bei
der gelegenheit sich erinnere mich genau
daran habe ich vor drei jahren von ihnen
den namen von katharina geschenke
bekommen die nämlich in berlin sich
aufhielt und ich hatte noch das glück
sie zu erwischen bevor sie zurück fuhr
in die ukraine wir uns lange unterhalten
im jüdischen museum hier in berlin auch
eine weitere autorin die fabelhaft
deutsch spricht und schreibt
und die hat gerade in einem interview
gesagt für europa sind ukrainische leben
weniger wert als andere
auch russische leben und solche sätze
fallen natürlich sehr sehr tief ich weiß
verblüfft von aus den letzten 14 tagen
das gefühl zu bekommen wie tapfer auf
der einen seite die all diese künstler
und künstlerinnen reden sie wie sie die
haltung zeigen wie vielfältig auch die
annahmen sind über das was passieren
wird wie absolut anrührend wie sehr sie
uns aber auch daran erinnern welche
verantwortung wir tragen wenn wir der
geschichte eingedenk sind denn das ist
ja dann doch eine sache die ukraine ist
ein europa im kleinen oder europa eine
ukraine im großen
dass wir eigentlich den prozess der
demokratisierung auch mit allen
problemen die ja auch schlögl nie
übersehen hat dass wir das eigentlich
nicht richtig wahrgenommen haben und vor
allem die gefahr nicht genügend ich
meine es nicht bücher bücher macherinnen
wie sie sondern die zivilgesellschaft in
deutschland hat er die ukraine als
problem als gefäß land nicht so auf der
auf dem schirm wie es richtig gewesen
wäre ist und dass das stimmt also man
muss aber zu ehren weiß nicht wer ist
uns die deutschland hat jedenfalls die
ganzen letzten jahre
sehr viel professionelle hilfe
investiert in den institutionellen
aufbau der der ukraine auf vielen
feldern also ich glaube deutschland hat
mit das meiste geld gegeben damit die
strukturen die wirtschaftsstrukturen
infrastrukturprojekte justizreform
polizeireform
korruptionsbekämpfung damit dass alles
auf die beine kommt also sagen hilfe
beim staatsaufbau aber die
öffentlichkeit und die die wahrnehmung
von menschen die jetzt nicht
professionell in den berater stäben
sitzen die eine enorme expertise haben
in deutschland die hatten die ukraine
nicht auf die warum können wir mal kurz
versuchen das zu ergründen auf einer
sage ich mal
nicht geschichts metaphysischen aber
doch eine etwas abgehobenen ebene das
ist überhaupt keine frage die ich mir
schon öfter und schon früher gestellt
habe wir schauen kaum nach polen schon
gar nicht in die ukrainische gar nicht
in die ost ukraine da wo sie unbekannt
wird für die allermeisten von uns und
natürlich noch weniger jenseits davon
ist das ein eine blindheit ist das ein
desinteresse das ist von allem ein
bisschen aber das
ist ein solcher kontrast zu dem was sie
gerade sagten die hilfe die ideelle die
materielle die logistische hilfe die
kulturbeziehungen die sich intensivieren
ich erwähne einmal dass literatur
festival von und des was das
internationale literaturfestival berlin
jedes jahr gemacht hat nämlich kurz nach
dem ereignis hier in berlin im september
sind sie im oktober mit aktivitäten in
odessa gewesen ich habe begeisterte
berichte davon gehört also es gibt diese
verbindung sie haben sie auch genannt
und dennoch kommt es im allergrößten
teil der bevölkerung nicht an mit der
folge dass wir die ukraine als
schützenswerte nation nie erkannt haben
kann man das so sagen ja
eine der wichtigsten akteuren auf diesem
feld hat vor wenigen tagen öffentlich
gesagt sie macht seit 17 jahren
kulturprojekte mit ukrainischen partnern
für deutsche institution festivals
lesungen symposien
mit akademien mit
stiftungen und sie hat sehr bitter
darüber gesprochen das ist trotzdem
nicht gereicht hat um dieses land
als teil unseres europäischen
bewusstseins zu verankern
und ich glaube das hat damit zu tun dass
die europäische wende die der
ost-west-konflikt und seine überwindung
ein projekt war das viel schwung hatte
in den neunziger jahren aber dass die
schwerkraft der verhältnisse dafür
gesorgt hat dass wir vor allem über
russland wahrgenommen haben russland war
das andere des westens russland war aber
deutschland immer sehr nah die menschen
der kultur haben dostojewski und tolstoi
gelesen man wusste irgendwie ein
bisschen was von von solchen entziehen
und es waren immer einzelne hoch aktive
leute ich möchte auch zum beispiel die
vielen städtepartnerschaften in
erinnerung rufen die ist ja gablenberg
freiburg
münchen und leipzig vor allem nürnberg
und kharkiv eine großartige
städtepartnerschaft deren wurzeln noch
in tschernobyl der
tschernobyl-katastrophe liegen das heißt
es gab sozusagen dieses salz der erde
überall und die große masse übrigens
auch die masse der zuschauer des
fernsehens die waren natürlich ungemein
verblendet durch diese sentimentalen
alten spd eliten und allen voran einer
so furchtbaren journalistin wie gabriele
krone schmalz die keine gelegenheit
ausgelassen hat ihr ihre niere ihre
meinungen die auf einem stand von 1991
oder 88 beruhten über das neue russland
so zu sprechen
als nehme sie nicht zur kenntnis was
dort geschehen ist und die ukraine war
immer im windschatten also ich erinnere
mich noch
viele leute haben gar nicht gewusst es
ist ein eigener staat ist es ist ja auch
schwierig die sowjetunion ist bei 91
zerfallen und es gab ich weiß nicht wie
viel neue botschaften eröffnet wurden
lauter neue stadt neuer hauptstädte
neuen namen wie soll man das auch alles
kapieren und die sprache das ukrainische
wer kann das schon osteuropa entspricht
17 sprachen der kann diese sprach nadel
und wir hatten auch wenig ressourcen
also die tollen ukrainisch übersetzerin
die es jetzt gibt die gab es in den 90er
jahren überhaupt noch nicht und das ist
alles ein großes bildungsprojekt gewesen
in das vielleicht doch zu wenig kraft
investiert worden ist ja das glaube ich
das kann man so sagen und deswegen
scheint mir das einzige was menschen die
mit kultur zu tun haben tun können ist
einfach weitermachen
ich möchte gerne noch zwei bücher
erwähnen die sie in den letzten im
letzten jahr gemacht haben die unser
thema auch berühren und dann noch sie
noch etwas fragen zu dem was kommt in
ihrem programm die beiden bücher die ich
erwähnen möchten eines heißt acht tage
revolution ein dokumentarisches journal
aus minsk von arthur kliniksprechers
lina sie ihn auch nie genau der hat
diese dieses kuriose der kritische
zeichen auf dem ruder dass ich dessen
namen ich vergessen habe kein hat schick
sondern was anderes arthur kino ist ein
schriftsteller und architekt aus belarus
und ich habe dieses tagebuch mit
absoluter faszination gelesen natürlich
ist man auch erschüttert findet bilder
für das was eben was eben nur geschenke
bedeutet der übervater der sich an der
macht hält die wahlen fälscht und er
beschreibt eigentlich aus dem zivilleben
ja wie sie es anfühlt von so einer figur
beherrscht zu werden von so einer art
diktatur beherrscht zu werden das zweite
buch was ich nennen möchte ist olga
sparern
shp schwager die revolution hat ein
weibliches gesicht der fall belarus
ebenfalls im letzten jahr erschienen
hochinteressant weil es natürlich das
thema aufgreift wie viele frauen
aktivistinnen autorinnen künstlerinnen
sind mutig sind nach vorne treten demus
machen sich nicht verstecken also ist
eine absolute umwertung eigentlich
dessen was die kundgebung ist hier sind
frauen die protagonistinnen wir erinnern
uns ja nicht zuletzt auch noch an die
russen die den mut hat sie in die
nachrichtensendung zu treten mit dem
schild [ __ ]
als letzte frage würde ich ganz gerne
wissen das kommende programm weil so kam
dass sie betreuen was verheißt uns dass
ich habe gehört es gibt einen neuen
roman von juri andere hobbys ja der neue
roman ist wirklich ein neuer roman weil
es seit ich glaube über 15 jahren zu
einem berg nicht mehr von ihm gegeben
hat das ist ein großer wurf es ist ein
buch über einen sogenannten barrikaden
pianisten der in einer ungenannten
revolution in einer ungenannten
postsowjetischen stadt
mit getan hat und dann fliehen muss weil
die revolution niedergeschlagen wird und
er jobbt heuer dann in einem schweizer
hotel als pianist und wer sitzt ihm
eines abends gegenüber den diktator sein
des ehemaligen landes und er nimmt ein
ei knallt es ihm an den kopf und der
diktator stirbt wann er kommt in den
knast und nachdem er entlassen ist
flieht er in die karpaten und dort ist
ihm ein unbekannter geheimdienst auf den
spuren er muss mit seiner geliebten und
mit dem raben edgar verschwinden wie ich
es wollen sie jetzt eigentlich hier das
ist alles alles alles noch vor eines aus
der trilogie und das ist alles der der
inhalt des romans aber natürlich ist
dieser skurrile plot nicht die
hauptsache sondern die hauptsache ist
und dass darin ist ein richtiger großer
android es ist ein feuerwerk von genres
und von tönen also ist in theaterszenen
da drin sind gedichte drin hinten auf
dem auf dem cover befindet sich 1 1 pcr
kommt nämlich pcr code wie heißt es qr
ein qr ein qr-code und da kann man alle
musikstücke herunterladen die in diesem
radionacht gespielt werden denn
radionacht dieser mann ins us ja jossi
brotzki und jeder jede leserin hört da
joseph roth
trotzki joseph brodsky und so weiter da
ist schon da steckt schon der ganze
andere hobbys drin in diesem in diesem
spiel und dieser hotkey findet das
letzte zuflucht eine insel ein eiland
null meridian und was tut er dort
ergründet ein radio nacht zu heißt das
und er sendet rund um die uhr in die
sich verfinstern de welt hinein poesie
musik
skurrile geschichten mir kommt dieses
buch vor wie das wie die summe all
dessen was android geschrieben hat weil
diese bei dieser geschichten kostenlos
und dieses kaleidoskop einfach
musikalisch funkeln mir bleibt da jetzt
nur zu sagen erst einmal 1000 st
katharina raabe dass sie da war und dann
dass ihre literatur und der diese zur
veröffentlichung verhelfen weiterhin
poesie nachrichten gedichte erzählungen
und anderes senden möge vielen dank für
ihre einladung und für das interesse
[Musik]
das gespräch mit katharina raabe habe
ich vor 14 tagen hier in berlin geführt
inzwischen ist sie in kalifornien wo sie
morgen an einer veranstaltung des
instituts für islamisches sprachen und
literaturen an der university of
california in berkeley teilnimmt dabei
ist auch die russische schriftstellerin
maria stefano war den veranstaltern geht
es darum durch lesungen und diskussionen
ich zitiere die würde der literatur in
zeiten des krieges zu verteidigen es
gibt keinen grund davon abzulassen auch
wenn das angesichts der bomben schwach
erscheint blass irgendwie zu wenig aber
wer sich nur vor augen hält was putins
imperiums theologie wirklich will
nämlich den raum für freiheit demokratie
und selbstbestimmtheit einzuengen
nämlich widerständigkeit und
heterogenität zu vernichten dem wirt
einleuchten dass jede opposition
jede gegenwehr beim denken selbst
beginnt und damit bei gedichten und
büchern
ich habe dann noch einmal mit katharina
raabe telefoniert um sie zu fragen was
sich in den letzten 14 tagen getan hat
und wie es ihren autoren in der ukraine
geht bei jeweils acht uhr morgens bei
mir 17 uhr am nachmittag
katharina misst schenkung so erzählte
mir katharina raabe
katharina mit schenk die mit ihrem
kleinen sohn vor wochen aus kiew in den
westen der ukraine geflogen war ist
inzwischen in berlin am
wissenschaftskolleg
von den anderen autoren ist bisher
nichts schlimmes bekannt wenn man mal
davon absieht dass serena dann
beschossen wurde er hält sich in charkiw
auf
und hier noch einmal wie versprochen
einige der genannten bücher buchtitel
zum leichteren mitschreiben oder
leichteren wiederfinden
das letzte territorium das sind die
essays von juri andruchowytsch aus dem
jahr 2003 über die wir freuen
ausführlich gesprochen haben
euro bei was in der ukraine auf dem
spiel steht ebenfalls herausgegeben von
juri andruchowytsch und mit einem foto
se von jewgeni below durchsetzt das ist
aus dem jahr 2014 unmittelbar nach der
annexion der kreml die beiträge sind ein
who's who der heutigen debatte übrigens
kurze zeit später 2015 erschien der band
testfall ukraine europa und seine werte
herausgegeben von katharina raabe und
karls apa denn dafür gilt ähnliches wie
für den zuvor genannten band
warum ich nicht im netz binden das sind
gedichte und prosa von tschechischer
dann über die wir vorher gesprochen
haben aus dem jahr 2016 leider immer
noch sehr gültig und dann habe ich noch
erwähnt acht tage revolution von ad hoc
lienau den belarussen aus dem jahre 2021
da geht es generell natürlich um die
politische schieflage in den
angrenzenden ländern und natürlich den
blick überhaupt osteuropäer belarussen
polen usw auf die lage in der ukraine
im selben kontext in einem weiteren
kontext würde ich noch nennen auf jeden
fall dass vilnius buch genius heißt ist
eine stadt in europa aus dem jahre 2006
schon des dichters thomas wenzlow war
der in hohem alter jetzt wieder in
wenings lebt aber auch eine ganze weile
in den usa gelehrt hat
der im letzten jahr verstorbene pole
adam zagajewski ein großer lyriker und
essayist hat ein band seiner ss mit dem
titel verteidigung der leidenschaft und
darin gibt es einen essay über limberg
die stadt in der er geboren wurde und
musste er als kind weg gebracht wurde
von seinen eltern herzlich ganz spät
wieder gesehen und davon sehr schön
erzählt lemberg ist auch das thema eines
buches von lutz cegh levermann
lemberg die vergessene mitte europas aus
dem jahr 2017 das ist deswegen
interessant weil das natürlich mit dem
wissen um 2014 und den
roman geschrieben ist das ist im grunde
ein spaziergang ein historischer
spaziergang und kultureller spaziergang
durch lemberg und eine neue sicht mit
eben diesem jahr mit der annexion decke
im hinterkopf und auch sehr zugänglich
geschrieben was man dazu wissen sollte
ist dass der name der stadt lemberg in
deutschland nahm er nur für einen
kleinen teil des jahrhunderts galt des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
später hiess i love mit akzent im
polnischen lodz wenn ich es gut aus
spreche im russischen ohne akzent und
ließ im ukrainischen das ist heute
lemberg
diese titel nenne ich auch um einen
größeren kontext anzuzeigen denn das
osteuropäische thema im weitesten sinne
hat seit 1989 eine große verschiebung
und veränderung erfahren wir sehen heute
dinge einfach ganz anders durch
geöffnete archive neue erkenntnisse und
neue zusammenhänge
hier möchte ich noch einmal auf den band
testfall ukraine hinweisen den ich
gerade genannt habe europa und seine
werte aus dem jahr 2015 darin findet
sich ein aufsatz des großartigen
historiker karl schlögel der dort
freimütig bekennt wie in seinem
werdegang seinem akademischen werdegang
die ukraine kaum eine rolle gespielt
habe weil er sie immer durch weder
russländischen oder sowjetische augen
auch in der geschichtsschreibung gesehen
hat das ist ein absolut hellsichtiger
sed
eigenes versäumnis
erklärt auch biografisch erklärt
und das gilt natürlich für ganz viele
von uns wir
nehmen gerade lektionen durch
nachhilfeunterricht in geschichte und
ich glaube wir müssen die ukraine als
land als kultur neu sehen lernen
überhaupt erst sehen lernen das ist das
zweitgrößte land in europa und wir
hatten es eigentlich nicht auf der karte
das kann man glaube ich sagen das hat
sich vor acht jahren geändert aber die
damaligen warnungen und die damaligen
analysen es gab einige sehr
scharfsinnige und hellsichtiger sind von
der großen mehrheit
nicht beachtet worden einige haben schon
damals gesehen dass damit eine
zeitenwende eintritt mit der annexion
der krim und mit putins aggression die
bücher über die wir heute gesprochen
haben reflektieren das zu einem großen
teil
[Musik]
wir haben noch etwas für sie hannover
klaus dort hat ein neues buch
geschrieben
am donnerstag dem 17 april kommt der
berühmte norwegische schriftsteller nach
frankfurt am main um abends um 19 30 im
schauspiel den roman der morgenstern
vorzustellen das literaturhaus frankfurt
veranstaltet die lesung zusammen mit dem
schauspiel frankfurt und das hat uns in
bücher podcast ihr zweimal zwei karten
zur verfügung gestellt die wir unter
unseren höheren verlosen können wenn sie
also carlo knauss dort am
donnerstagabend in frankfurt live
erleben möchten schicken sie uns bitte
eine mail
an die übliche adresse bücher - podcast
faz.de bücher mit der uns als erstes und
als zweites schreibt findet auf seinen
namen je zwei tickets am ehrenkarten
tisch im schauspiel foyer dazu
benachrichtigen wir sie natürlich recht
schnell die gerade genannte e mail
adresse gilt auch für kommentare aller
art die sie uns zukommen lassen möchten
wir freuen uns doch er war am nächsten
sonntag gibt es hier in bücher podcast
eine sonderfolge aus dem literaturhaus
frankfurt nämlich eine lesung mit monika
helfer und michael köhlmeier in 14 tagen
ist dann wieder der kollege kai spanke
mit sachbüchern dran und wir hören uns
wieder wenn sie mögen am ersten mai bis
dahin machen sie es gut
[Musik]